hey what is up guys mkbhd here and a
short while ago on this youtube channel
we passed 3 million subscribers 3
million of you guys which is pretty
awesome and i am more than willing to
celebrate especially around this time of
year the holiday season by giving back
so short and sweet let's just get right
into it i'm going to be giving away a
nexus 6p an iphone 6s plus a samsung
galaxy s6 edge plus an lg v10 and a
oneplus 2. so all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and drop a
comment below that like button of which
one you want to win there will be five
total winners and that's it that's all
you got to do if you're feeling lucky my
buddy john over at the crispy approved
tld today youtube channel is also
holding a giveaway right now he's
celebrating 1 million subscribers well
he's about to so definitely head over to
that card right there to check out his
video subscribe to get him to a million
and he's giving away a surface book
fresh unused a pair of blue headphones
an iphone 6s
galaxy s6 and a 12 inch macbook so
there's plenty of dope tech up for grabs
you have one week to enter it's
international and all the rules and
everything will be listed below and you
should follow us on twitter because
that's where we're going to be
announcing the winners one week from now
is right after christmas so right around
the new year so even if you don't get
the gift you want you can rest easy
knowing you can start off the new year
with some fresh new tech either way
that's basically it hope you guys
enjoyed if you're a subscriber already
thank you for being one if you're new
here hi and welcome aboard thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace